♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW, HIS
FIRST TIME ON "HANNITY," THE
OWNER OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS
AND THE HIT SHOW "SHARK TANK."
I LOVE THAT SHOW.
IT’S A GREAT SHOW.
MARK CUBAN, HOW ARE YOU, SIR?
>> I’M DOING GREAT, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON.
>> Sean: I HAVE A GROUP PLAN
TO REOPEN MBA AND WANT TO THROW
IN VALUE.
I’VE BEEN TALKING TO OWNERS OF
OTHER SPORTS FRANCHISES, ROBERT
KRAFT, RANDY LEVINE, ALL THOSE
GUYS.
OKAY.
MAYBE YOU CAN PLAY BASKETBALL
OUTSIDE.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT WORKS
IN WHATEVER THE STADIUM --
WHEREVER THE GAME IS BEING HELD,
THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE COVID TEST
THAT DAY, NOW MORE AVAILABLE
THAN EVER BEFORE.
YOU TAKE -- YOU HAVE THE
TEMPERATURE -- I WILL SHOW YOU
THIS THING ON THE SCREEN, IT’S
CALLED A TEMPERATURE TURNSTILE,
YOU WALK THROUGH IT, TAKE THE
TEMPERATURE, YOU HAVE A HIGH
TEMPERATURE YOU’RE NOT ALLOWED
ADMISSION.
THEN WE HAVE THIS REALLY COOL
MASK THAT PEOPLE WILL GET IF
THEY GO WATCH THE
DALLAS MAVERICKS AND IT’S A
DALLAS MAVERICKS BASKETBALL MASK
TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
IF YOU WANT TO GO TO THE GAME
YOU’VE GOT TO WEAR THE MASK JUST
LIKE THE MEDICAL MANUFACTURERS
DID AND THE GUYS THAT STOCK THE
SHELVES IN NEW YORK AND YOU CAN
DRINK BEER THROUGH A STRAW,
MAYBE EAT A HOT DOG IF YOU PUT
YOUR MASK ON QUICK, WITHOUT
WORK?
>> WITH PLAY GAMES OUTSIDE
BEFORE, SO YOU’RE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THERE.
I’M NOT AS BIG A FAN OF THE
TEMPERATURE CHECK BECAUSE IF YOU
JUST EAT THREE QUICK EXTRA
STRENGTH TYLENOL YOU CAN BEAT
THOSE TESTS, BUT WE ARE GETTING
TO THAT POINT, SEAN, WHERE WE
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE DO SOME
TEST DATES -- TESTING AND
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO PLAY GAMES
AGAIN.
I DON’T THINK WE ARE READY FOR
FANS YET BUT LET US TAKE THAT
FIRST STEP.
>> Sean: WHAT IF YOU DID EVERY
OTHER SEAT?
IF YOU GET A BIG STADIUM, RIGHT,
THE EQUIVALENT OF
YANKEE STADIUM -- --
>> WHEN WE GET TO WHERE WE CAN
HAVE FANS, WE CAN QUARANTINE
PEOPLE TOGETHER.
RIGHT?
SO IT FURTHER -- THE HANNITY
FAMILY COMES TOGETHER, WE DON’T
NEED TO PUT SEATS BETWEEN ALL OF
THEM.
THE CUBAN FAMILY, HANNITY
FAMILY, WE CAN QUARANTINE, GROUP
PEOPLE TOGETHER, BUT WE HAVE TO
TAKE OUR FIRST STEPS FIRST AND
MAKE SURE ALL THE PLANS THAT WE
HAVE ARE EFFECTIVELY SAFE.
>> Sean: LISTEN, I WANT THAT,
SPORTS ARE A BIG PART OF THE
AMERICAN CULTURE, PSYCHE.
I’M WILLING TO WEAR A MASK TO
GO.
I WILL WEAR IT, I WILL GO
THROUGH ANYTHING ELSE, I WILL
DRINK MY BEER THROUGH A STRAW.
YOU SAID ABOUT DONALD TRUMP -- I
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS.
YOU SAID YOUR SUPPORTING BIDEN
AND YOU SAID YOU WOULD PREFER
HIM -- OKAY.
HE’S, YOU KNOW -- I DON’T HAVE A
PROBLEM -- WE HAVE DIFFERENT
POLITICS.
LET’S START WITH CORONAVIRUS
ALONE.
YOU TELL ME ALL THE THINGS
BUNKER JOE DID ON CORONAVIRUS
THAT YOU ADMIRE AND THEN I WILL
TELL YOU WHAT I THINK PROMPTED
THAT I ADMIRE.
LET’S START THAT WAY.
>> WELL, JOE IS NOT IN CHARGE OF
ANYTHING RIGHT NOW, RIGHT?
IS A CANDIDATE SO WE CAN’T
REALLY PUT HIM IN THAT CATEGORY.
BUT I WILL LISTEN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK -- I MEAN,
WHAT HAVE WE GOT TO LOSE TO
LISTEN TO WHAT YOU SAID THAT
DONALD DID RIGHT?
>> YEAH, BUT THE POINT IS, HE
CALLED THE TRAVEL BAN --
DONALD TRUMP, WILL YOU GIVE THEM
CREDIT, TEN DAYS AFTER THE FIRST
KNOWN CORONA CASE IN AMERICA,
TRAVEL BAN.
>> 100% CREDIT.
>> Sean: QUARANTINE, FIRST IN
50 YEARS, THE SUBSEQUENT TRAVEL
BAN’S, GOOD IDEAS?
>> YEP.
>> Sean: WE ALL KNOW THE
MODELS ON THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WERE WRONG AND I’M
NOT BLAMING THEM.
CHINA LIED TO THE WORLD.
>> THEY’RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
100% ACCURATE, THEY’RE SUPPOSED
TO BE GUIDELINES.
>> Sean: SO TRUMP BUILD ALL
THE HOSPITALS IN NEW YORK, HE
BUILT -- AND SENT HIS NAVY
HOSPITAL SHIP.
HE SAID EVERY VENTILATOR, EVERY
SHIELD, EVERY MASK, GLOVES,
GOWNS, EVERYTHING, BECAUSE
NEW YORK WAS PREPARED FOR
NOTHING.
AND HE GOT -- EVEN CONVERTED
THOSE HOSPITALS TO COVID-19
CAPABILITY.
YOU WENT ON SAYING THAT
DONALD TRUMP HASN’T DONE A
GOOD JOB WITH THIS.
I WOULD ARGUE HE DID A
PHENOMENAL JOB AND SAVED
NEW YORK’S ASS.
>> I WAS INVOLVED IN SOME OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND WHAT
HAPPENED WAS WHEN PPE GOT IN
SHORT SUPPLY, WHAT I SUGGESTED
THAT THEY DO WAS MATCH UP THE
DEMAND ALONG WITH THE SUPPLY.
BUT THEY WOULDN’T DO THAT,
RIGHT, SO NO ONE WOULD TAKE
INVENTORY OF WHERE ALL THE PPP
WAS AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
BECAUSE THEY WOULDN’T PRESENT
THAT MARKET INFORMATION,
HOSPITALS STARTED HOARDING AND
WE DIDN’T KNOW WHERE THE
MANUFACTURING SOURCES WERE
COMING FROM, SO WE GOT INTO EVEN
MORE -- IN GREATER SHORT SUPPLY
OF PPE.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FIX THAT.
THEY KNEW THEY COULD HAVE FIXED
IT, BUT THEY DIDN’T TAKE THE
ACTUAL STEPS BECAUSE NO ONE WAS
TRULY IN CHARGE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REALLY HAD -- HE
HAD THE RIGHT IDEA INPUTTING THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE, BUT HE HAD ONE
GROUP DOING ONE THING, ANOTHER
GROUP DOING ANOTHER THING --
>> Sean: I CAN TELL YOU THAT’S
NOT TRUE.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR CUOMO -- HANG
ON.
IN NOVEMBER OF 2015, HIS OWN
TASK FORCE SAID IN PEAK WEEK
YOU’LL BE SHY 15,783 VENTILATORS
VENTILATORS.
NEW YORK MAYOR, de BLASIO SAID
THEY NEEDED 10,000.
THEY HAD NOTHING, ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
NOW, JARED KUSHNER MANAGED EVERY
VENTILATOR.
THEY SENT EVERY BIT OF MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT, THEY MANNED THE
CENTER, 3,000 VETS, THEY MANNED
THE HOSPITAL -- THEY CONVERTED
THEM AND CHANGE THE VENTILATION
SYSTEM.
NEW YORK WAS DEAD WITHOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT’S JUST A FACT.
>> SO YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT ON
JARED AND WHAT HE DID, THE
PROBLEM WAS HE WASN’T THE ONLY
ONE WORKING ON IT.
THERE WERE MULTIPLE GROUPS
WORKING ON THE SAME THING AND
THAT CREATED CONFUSION.
ARE YOU RIGHT ABOUT NEW YORK?
YES.
DID THEY HANDLE IT CORRECTLY?
NO.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN HANDLED A LOT
BETTER, ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
AND ON TOP OF THAT WHEN WE
STARTED DEALING WITH
VENTILATORS, AND THIS IS BOTH
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE STATE OF
NEW YORK -- WHEN WE STARTED
GETTING ALL THESE VENTILATOR
DEATHS, NOBODY DID A THING.
THERE WERE REPORTS SAYING THAT
80% OF PEOPLE IN VENTILATORS
WERE DYING.
ELDERLY [INAUDIBLE]
-- THEY WERE DYING, BUT THE
STATE LEVEL OR THE FEDERAL LEVEL
CAME OUT AND SAID STOP USING SO
MANY VENTILATORS.
BOTH PARTIES MADE MISTAKES AND
IT COST PEOPLE THEIR LIVES.
>> Sean: BUT YOU CAN’T ASK THE
WHITE HOUSE TO MAKE MEDICAL
DECISIONS FOR HOSPITALS AND
DOCTORS.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, BECAUSE YOU
SAID YOUR SUPPORTING BIDEN,
WHICH I DON’T -- YOU ARE TOO
SMART -- I’VE WATCHED YOU ON
"SHARK TANK."
YOU’RE TOO GOOD INTO SMART AND
TOO GOOD A BUSINESSMAN, IT
DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME.
ALL RIGHT, LET ME SHOW YOU A
MONTAGE OF YOUR CANDIDATE AND
THEN YOU TELL ME OUT OF THIS
MONTAGE THAT YOU’RE GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS GUY.
AND EXPLAIN WHY.
I’M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND YOUR
THINKING BECAUSE I THINK A LOT
OF YOU -- I THINK YOU’RE A GOOD
OWNER FOR THE NBA, AN OUTSPOKEN
ENTREPRENEUR, YOU’RE CAPITALIST.
AS JOE BIDEN, YOUR CHOICE FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> INTRODUCED ME?
I’M ION?
GOOD EVENING.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR TUNING IN.
>> LOOK, TOMORROW’S SUPERSTAR
TUESDAY AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL -- I TELL YOU WHAT, I’M
RUSHING AHEAD AREN’T I?
WE OWE THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT?
ALL MEN -- YOU KNOW THE THING.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH ME?
GO TO JOE, 3330.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE THINGS I
LIKE ABOUT MARK CUBAN ON "SHARK
TANK" IS YOU CALL IT AS IT IS.
NOW, LET ME ASK YOU --
>> JOE BIDEN IS THE KING OF MALA
PROSS, --
>> Sean: NO.
NO.
DO YOU THINK THAT GUY -- YOU
DON’T THINK THIS GUY -- IF HE
HAD A FASTBALL, CURVEBALL, SLOW
PITCH, THAT THEY’RE ALL GONE?
COME ON, THAT DOESN’T SCARE YOU?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, BOTH SIDES
SCARE ME.
I’M NOT GOING TO LIE, SEAN.
JOE BIDEN SCARES ME IN SOME
AREAS AND PRESIDENT TRUMP OF
SCARES ME MORE AREAS RIGHT NOW
AND I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT DONALD
DOESN’T PUT THE BEST PEOPLE IN
PLACE ANY LONGER.
HE DID AT THE BEGINNING AND I
WAS PROUD OF HIM AT THE
BEGINNING, BUT NOW HE JUST WANTS
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOYAL TO HIM
THAT’S A PROBLEM AND IT’S
CREATED MORE PROBLEMS IN THIS
PANDEMIC.
>> Sean: IF YOU HAD AS MANY
KNIVES IN YOUR NECK AND SHAVES
IN YOUR NECK LIKE HE’S GOT, HE
WOULD PROBABLY WANT TO FIRE
THOSE PEOPLE TOO.
PRIOR TO COVID, RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC IN THE COUNTRY, SO
THE BIDEN AND OBAMA NEVER PULLED
OFF.
LAST WORD.
>> THERE’S NO QUESTION HE
DESERVES A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE ECONOMY.
BUT THOSE DAYS ARE BEHIND US
NOW, BUT HE CAME UPON THE
VICTIM -- THIS IS WHAT REALLY
BOTHERS ME ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
HE’S THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN
THE WORLD AND HE ALWAYS PLAYS
THE VICTIM CARD.
THE DEMS ARE OUT TO GET ME, THE
MEDIA IS OUT TO GET ME.
YOU’VE GOT TO BE THE LEADER,
YOU’VE GOT TO BE THE STRONGEST
MAN IN THE GAME.
>> Sean: MARK.
MARK.
THEY SPIED ON THE GUY.
THEY SPIED ON A CANDIDATE WHOSE
TRANSITION TEAM -- THEY SPIED ON
HIS PRESIDENCY.
THOSE ARE BILL BARR’S WORDS, NOT
SEAN HANNITY.
>> WHO CARES?
IS THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN THE
WORLD.
BE POWERFUL, BE A LEADER.
>> Sean: AND HE FOUGHT BACK.
>> YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
WORLD’S BEST COUNTERPUNCH, HE
HASN’T BEEN ABLE TO KNOCK
ANYBODY OUT, HE JUST PLAYS THE
VICTIM.
I LOVE THE WAY YOU STAND UP ALL
THIS PEOPLE THAT CALL HIM OUT,
THAT’S A GREAT THING, SEAN, BUT
THE MAN HAS GOT TO BE A LEADER
AND HE HASN’T SHOWN THAT YET.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW ONE THING
HE’S NEVER GOING TO DO?
HE’S DONALD TRUMP.
HE GOT ELECTED AS DONALD TRUMP,
HE SAVED THE COUNTRY IS
DONALD TRUMP AND HE’LL BRING THE
COUNTRY BACK AS DONALD TRUMP.
I WANT TO SIT NEXT TO YOU DURING
THE FIRST GAME WHEN YOUR TEAM
OPENS UP.
I WILL SIT NEXT TO YOU AND I
WON’T BRING ANY NEW YORK COVID
WITH ME, I PROMISE.
>> I TELL YOU WHAT, I WANT TO
WATCH YOU EAT THAT HOTDOG
THROUGH THE MASK.
>> Sean: THIS IS WHAT YOU DO,
YOU TAKE THE MASS, YOU SHOVE IT
UNDER -- YOU TAKE A BITE AND
THEN YOU JUST GOT TO CHEW IT.
GOD FORBID IF YOU GET THE HOTDOG
YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT WOULD BE
UGLY.